what is the biggest difference between
hoody fans and Darius record country
fans Darius Rucker country fans don't
ask me when hoody is getting back this
is Darius Rucker unfiltered in honor of
his fifth studio album Darius and I
shared a bottle of his signature
backstage whiskey backstage of course at
a recent show in Nashville for an
interview under the influence
[Music]
I got a I got a shout-out on this label
it says no curfew tonight good now I
understand there's a story behind this
name though tell me where that came from
well you know this was it started a the
backstage was we thought was a great
name because of what I do but it all
started back in back in the day and like
I think 97 and and I mean who do you we
were on tour with a Slash's Snakepit
where the backstage we look at our
trailer and our trailer it's it's us and
eight other guys is like 12 dudes in
this trailer and we look right next door
and then the glass in the window we see
slash it's slash and like 12 girls we
look at this and so that night we drank
some whiskey to slash do you still like
every night everybody bill you toast to
slash every night every night we toast
the slash I love that so much
[Music]
is whiskey drunk different from other
kinds of Julia what is a whiskey drunk
first shot of whiskey is the best
example that's what you look like the
rest of the night you drink it and for a
second like oh that's good then for
about I don't know maybe 15 17 seconds
your chest it doesn't get really warm
yes and you're like don't you're talking
to people but you're like but chances
getting really warm then all of a sudden
yourself you send them to this great
mellow and that's well let's get into
the game here now here's how it's gonna
work I'm gonna ask you a question you
have the option to answer my question
and I will take a shot if you plead the
fifth and do not want to answer the
question you have to take a shot okay
got it
so let's start with the first one that I
think everybody wants to know and you've
probably been asked before does everyone
still call you hoody and does it drive
you insane oh it doesn't happen very
often anymore
Rarity's I mean don't get me wrong so
happy you know but it's rare now very
but you know I'm really glad they still
Know Who I am I know I said that before
but that is just okay I still can't
believe that when I name the van who
does that oh goodness
did you ever like freak out about it
no all right okay now do I sip this or
throw it back that was like a glass of
water
[Laughter]
hit the mellow have you ever written a
song while drunk and has it ever heard
the light of day yes
I've won a Grammy for a song I wrote
just absolutely
[Music]
just really really after a long night
I've never waking up the next afternoon
and it's just really laughing because
I'm like I gotta hear this song oh it's
gonna be pretty funny and and playback
it was a letter cried and I was like
that's not very funny
yeah that was pretty good too for me
cheers again just throwing them down
whoo read us your last text exchange
with Luke Ryan Willie Robertson or Jason
Aldean Oh
Jason to Lucas that uh Jason look uh no
I wouldn't do that
explain your most awkward run-in you've
ever had with another celebrity this was
95 we were just really started to to get
and we were at this we were at the Pro
Bowl in Hawaii and we were trying to get
into this party that was going on those
NFL party and we would get there and we
thought we were on the guest list but
they wouldn't let us in and drew bledsoe
walked up behind us and grabbed us also
hey man there okay that was pretty awful
all right I'll take it
although I'm actually I think we both
should be good don't think that was an
awkward awkward no that's great Cheers
what is your least favorite song to
perform live
I love how your music has spanned
generations there are parents and kids
and all sorts of people from all walks
of life know your music know every word
given the span of your career have you
had interactions with fans that have
made you feel old
oh goodness yeah yeah there was this one
time where I'm walking up and it's just
a bunch of people and you know me and
the crew and everything and people
trying to get autographs and I'm signing
autographs I'm signing off and
everything that happens all the time but
this time when it happened it was just
so funny that you get down your side and
then they say it all the time my mom
loves you okay we got that I got that I
got to one get one little girls who go
there she's like 10 years old and yes he
looked at me said all right I'll drink
to that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is shag marry kill oh god I hate
this game
pop stars of 1994 mister 1994 yes Mariah
Carey Madonna and Toni Braxton oh I got
a drink of that I don't answer that well
that right that's not fair haha
even the playing field alright so we are
neck and neck here
I know oh it burns so good yeah perform
later so we're just getting you ready
for that right yeah what is the biggest
difference between hoody fans and Darius
record country fans Darius Rucker
country fans don't ask me with hoodies
[Laughter]
thank you
you know bears and the bear said I can't
hey this is Darius Rucker and seriously
always drink responsibly okay and go and
subscribe to e t--'s youtube channel
because it's a lot of fun
[Music]